Ce matin j'étais sur Mégaupload pour télécharger le... ummm... umm
Le film de vacances de mes parents
Non je déconne, je téléchargeais illégalement un film parce que j'aime tuer l'industrie du cinéma
Bref, j'étais sur Mégaupload et je regardais les publicités qu'il y avait sur le site
Et j'ai perdu foi en l'humanité
Mon top 5 des pubs que j'ai pu croiser
tu veux me voir nue?
Attention c'est pas '' tu veux la voir nue?'' c'est tu veux me voir nue?''
Genre il existerait une fille sur terre, absolument bonne
Qui a envie de faire un petit sondage comme ça en mettant sa photo, pour savoir si les gens ont envie quoi..
Sondage absolument pas biaisé par cette énorme paire de nichons
Non, mais sérieux.. C'est quoi cette pub? hein?
Qui va cliquer sur non? Et même si tu cliques sur non? Il se passe quoi!?
''Non, félicitations vous êtes homosexuel'' Sérieux?
Autres genre, la pub que j'ai croisé le plus souvent, la plus moche, et la moins française aussi
''Le secret pour perdre du poids à découvert''
Ils avaient le choix entre ''à découvrir'' ou ''a été découvert'' mais non il faut qu'ils fassent le mix parfait des deux
Qui ne veux rien dire hein? D'ailleurs la phrase qui suit n'est pas mieux non plus ''j'ai perdu 2 kilos par semaine de graisse''
Non, malheureusement dans la langue française on peut pas mettre les mots dans l'ordre qu'on veut, c'est con hein!
Dans la lignée des questions débiles : '' Tu veux une copine sexy?''
Non, non non, je veux une copine dégueulasse, édentée, bien grosse avec des croûtes entre les bourlets, un oeil de verre et qui boîte
Pourquoi?
Ils nous prennent pour des cons
Une pub pour un fortifiant musculaire
On est bien d'accord ?
Une pub c'est fait pour donner envie
Qui a envie de ressembler à ce monstre, sérieux?
C'est une blague? les mecs qui ont faits cette pub ils ont rien compris!
Bon, alors pour la pub j'ai pensé à cette photo.
WHOA, whooo, ahhhh... Super! On la garde
Je savais que tu allais dire ça
(Nausée)
Et pour finir ma publicité préférée impossible de la louper, elle est énorme
Lisez bien la première phrase
''Hey... c'est quand la dernière que tu as eu fille aussi sexy?
Il manque un mot dans la phrase!
Incroyable, ça montre que les mecs s'en battent les couilles de la publicité
c'est la première pub que je vois où il manque un mot, quand même!
L'Oréal, parce que je le bien! - Coupé! Il manque un mot, mais on la garde
Voilà, c'étais juste une petite vidéo bonus que vous pouvez partager sur facebook et vous pouvez retrouver toutes mes autres vidéos sur cyprien.fr aussi
À bientôt!
Et même si tu clique sur non?, Il se passe quoi? Charles passe quoi